is it okay to just like use a cell phone
camera to record video your users is
there any like minimum required video
product the honestly the minimum
required video product is like a flip
phone from the 90s okay right it you it
recording video is the most important
thing as long as you have some kind of
video from some angle somewhere and it
works great no ideal you have a cell
phone cell phone videos fine laptop is
fine if you have a professional camera
feel free to bring it but actually
sometimes bringing a professional camera
is too much right you don't need that
quality that high quality video right
you're not making an apple promo video
all you need is enough to put up on a
conference room screen for somebody else
to see either a VC or PM or your
engineers right or even other designers
right because humans are really good at
figuring out the emotionally important
video even if it's grainy and low res
yeah never yeah and if you do bring a
big professional camera it might make
your test subjects feel a little bit
intimidated right you don't need to
bring lights you don't need to bring
like a boom microphone or anything like
that right just like have a little cell
phone camera prop it up on something you
can get one of those little like twisty
tripods to stick your camera on there
like a little like there are other
little tiny flip cams little video
cameras with actual like quarter inch
holes in the bottom to stick onto
tripods right those work great too and
but that the main goal is keep it
informal so that people don't feel
intimidated but just collect some kind
of video right one thing to note is that
audio is also really important and so
cell phone is generally to a pretty good
job of recording audio but it's worth
checking the audio to make sure that you
can understand what the people are
saying you know again you don't need a
boom like you don't need to mic the
person but it's really useful to make
sure that you can hear them right one
thing you can actually do is buy a
separate higher quality audio recorder
which tend to be fairly small and
unobtrusive hit record put it on the
table leave it there running clap or
something in the video to sync up the
audio and the video and then just leave
the audio out of the
you recorder and use the audio from the
table recorder which tends to be much
better awesome mm-hmm thank you